IT LOOKS LIKE SHERIFF CLARKE
AND THE REST WERE PRETTY
MUCH RIGHT IS ANYONE GOING
TO ISSUE A CORRECTION ON
THAT?
HE WOULD WAITING FOR IT
WELL, GOOGLE IS POLICING THE
CONTENT POSTED TO YOUTUBE
AND THEY ARE USING
THOROUGHLY DISCREDITED LEFT
WING GROUP TO DO THAT.
GOOGLE IS CREATING A GROUP
OF TRUSTED FLAGGERS WHO WILL
HELP THE COMPANY MONITOR
ALLEGED EXTREME ISLES
CONTENT ON THE WEBB SIGHT.
ONE OF THOSE TRUSTED
FLAGGERS IS NOT TRUSTED AT
ALL.
IT'S THE SOUTHERN POVERTY
LAW CENTER
LAW.CENTER
IT'S NOT EXPERT ON THE SOUTH
OR POVERTY OR LAW.
JOHN STOSSEL AMAZING TRUTH
ABOUT THIS GROUP.
HERE IS A PART OF IT?
>> THE SOUTHERN POVERTY LAW
CENTER BASED IN THAT
BUILDING IN ALABAMA CALLS
ITSELF THE PREMIER GROUP
MONITORING HATE GROUPS.
LOOKING AT THEIR MAP OF SUCH
GROUPS, YOU WOULD THINK
AMERICA WAS CONSUMED BY
HATE.
I ONCE BELIEVED IN THE
CENTER'S MISSION.
WELL-MEANING PEOPLE STILL
DO.
APPLE JUST GAVE THEM A
MILLION DOLLARS.
BUT WHAT DONORS DON'T KNOW
IS THAT TODAY THE CENTER
SMEARS PEOPLE WHO DON'T
DESERVE TO BE SMEARED.
THE SOUTHERN POVERTY LAW
CENTER NOW LISTS PEOPLE LIKE
BEN CARSON, LAURA INGRAHAM
AND JEANNE PIRRO AS
EXTREMISTS.
BUT IT DOESN'T LIST ANTIFA,
THE HATE GROUP THAT BEATS UP
PEOPLE ON THE RIGHT.
[SCREAMS]
>> CENTER HAS BECOME A HATE
GROUP ITSELF.
IT'S NOW A LEFT WING MONEY
GRABBING SLANDER MACHINE.
>> Tucker: IT'S A HATE
GROUP.
IT IS A HATE GROUP, TOO.
LET'S BE HONEST ABOUT THAT.
SHIVER IS A TECH
ENTREPRENEUR.
HE JOINS US TONIGHT.
YOU FOLLOW THIS STUFF
CLOSELY.
HOW DID THE SOUTHERN POVERTY
LAW CENTER WHOLLY
DISCREDITED AND WHOLLY
POLITICAL WIND UP RELEASING
CONTENT ON THE MOST POWERFUL
COMPANY IN THE WORLD.
HOW DID THAT HAPPEN?
>> IT'S HARD TO UNDERSTAND.
I THINK WHAT'S GOING ON,
TUCKER, IS THAT THESE -- YOU
KNOW, YOUTUBE IN ESSENCE WAS
TRYING TO BE INCLUSIVE IN
THEIR MIND AND REALLY TRYING
TO HAVE AN OPTICAL
PERSPECTIVE THAT THEY WERE
GOING AND DOING EVERYTHING
THEY COULD.
BECAUSE THEY WERE TAKING A
LOT OF HEAT FROM PEOPLE
SAYING THEY WEREN'T DOING
ENOUGH TO STOP ISIS AND
EXTREMIST GROUPS.
>> Tucker: RIGHT.
>> THAT'S WHAT LED TO THIS.
IT SHIFTS TOO FAR.
I CAN'T IMAGINE HOW THEY CAN
HAVE THIS GROUP AND REALLY
IN MY OPINION, MORE SHOULD
BE DONE AND A LOT MORE.
>> Tucker: SO, I MEAN, FOR
PEOPLE WATCHING AT HOME, WHO
THINK THAT SOUTHERN POVERTY
LAW CENTER SOUNDS LIKE A
LEGITIMATE GROUP, GIVE US AN
EXAMPLE OF THE PEOPLE OR
MOVEMENTS OR WEB SITES THEY
HAVE DEEMED OUT, YOU KNOW,
BEYOND THE PALE, HATER,
EXTREMISTS, WHO HAVE THEY
CALLED THAT.
>> LAURA INGRAHAM.
BEN CARSON.
SO HAVE YOU GOT CONSERVATIVE
FIGURES THAT THEY ARE
LABELING AND I THINK IT'S
GONE TOO FAR.
IT REALLY, IN MY OPINION,
YOUTUBE SHOULD FIRE SOUTHERN
POVERTY IMMEDIATELY FROM ALL
YOUTUBE MONITORING BECAUSE
IT'S AN OUTRAGE.
I MEAN, TO HAVE THE
POSSIBILITY OF AN
ANTI-CONSERVATIVE HITTING
DELETE FOR PARTISAN REASONS
OR ON ANY CONTENT THAT'S
RELEVANT PATRIOTIC
AMERICANS.
AND I THINK GOOGLE REALLY
NEEDS TO BE AND YOUTUBE BE
TRANSPARENT.
I MEAN, MOVING FORWARD.
TO MONITOR CONTENT AND HAVE
A NO POLICY RELATED TO
ANYONE THAT HAS ANY
POLITICAL AFFILIATION OR ANY
REPUTATION FOR BEING
PARTISAN.
AND I THINK, ALSO, THERE
REALLY NEEDS TO BE AN
APOLOGY TO PATRIOTIC
AMERICANS THAT USE YOUTUBE
FOR THIS GROSS OVERSIGHT AND
UNFAIR PROCESS THAT'S REALLY
DONE NOT WITH ANY KIND OF
DISCLOSURE.
IN THE CHOICE OF USING
SOUTHERN POVERTY TO THE
MONITORING OF CONTENT.
IT JUST DOESN'T MAKE SENSE.
FRANKLY, IT OPENS UP A BUNCH
OF THINGS.
I MEAN, WHEN THEY ARE DOING.
>> Tucker: YEAH, IT DOES.
>> DOING IT TO
CONSERVATIVES, WHO ELSE ARE
THEY DOING IT TOO.
>> Tucker: WE DON'T KNOW.
TOTALLY OPAQUE.
WHATEVER HAPPENED TO SAYING
WHAT YOU THINK IS TRUE EVEN